hello how many languages can you speak
one two maybe three or you could impress
us with even more languages but guess
what google's new machine translation
system can translate between more than a
thousand languages we bet no one can do
that
in this video we will basically
summarize the 57 pages of this paper for
you to see what the researchers had to
do to collect data for more than a
thousand languages how they trained
their machine translation models and in
which ways they surprised us
so grab a cup of coffee because it is
time to discuss about multilingual
transformers in this ai coffee break
but first let's thank weights and biases
for sponsoring today's video weights and
biases is an ml ops platform helping you
and your team improve the process of
building and maintaining machine
learning models it helps with experiment
tracking saving model configurations for
easy reproduction hyper parameter search
and many other things it gets even
better because weights and biases lives
where you work stay focused on training
models in whichever machine learning
library you know and love weights and
biases has callbacks or loggers for
keras pipe torch lightning hugging phase
yolo version 5 mm detection and more
just pass one line of code to turn on
experiment tracking model checkpointing
and data visualization and get back to
training your models
for example when using hugging phase
transformers just set report 2 1db in
the trainer arguments to turn on logging
if you're a keras user just pass the 1db
callback to the fit method and if you're
a pytorch lightning user then passing
the 1db logger to the trainer will turn
on rich logging of your experiment
metrics and system performance metrics
for free go to 1db dot me ai coffee
break to find out more about weights and
biases
now back to the video today we are
talking about machine translation models
like the ones behind google translate
as you've maybe already noticed with
google translate while for some language
pairs like english and german the
translation quality is impressive for
rarer language pairs the translation
quality can be lower although we cannot
really demonstrate this for german
romanian or other language pairs i speak
since the algorithms are probably based
on transformer models and have improved
their performance quite a lot lately but
the bad news still remains that some
languages are not even covered by google
translate
one reason for this is that it is hard
to find enough training data for them
and google translate is just an example
the problem that some languages work
better than others is well known for
machine translation systems not just for
google translate languages for which you
can find a lot of text on the internet
so high resource languages like english
german french spanish have high machine
translation quality because you know the
motto of training neural networks the
more data the better
but there are lots and lots of low
resource languages for which you can
find very little or no data on the world
wide web just so you get an idea there
are more than 7 000 languages spoken in
the world today but machine translation
systems have been built for around 100
languages so far for which the data
collection was easy and where there is
more economical incentive to cover a
language
as the paper points out we cite despite
high speaker populations languages
spoken in africa south and south east
asia and indigenous languages of the
americas are relatively underserved for
example google translate supports
frisian maltese icelandic and corsican
each with fewer than one million native
speakers but not up until this work puri
oromo and so on so the authors refer to
these languages as long tail languages
since the data scarcity requires the
application of machine learning
techniques that can generalize beyond
the languages for which ample training
data is available
so the idea of this paper is if we want
to go far beyond hundreds of languages
to reach the order of magnitude of the
thousands the authors need to crawl a
data set that captures the long tail too
easy right
no it turned out to be much harder than
i thought no wonder this paper is such a
long one describing a lot of the
problems that can arise when trying to
collect data for low resource languages
but first what kind of data are we
talking about the training data of
modern neural machine translation
systems is a mix of parallel and
monolingual data parallel data is key
for machine translation because it means
that for each sentence in a language we
have the same sentence in a different
language clearly this data should be the
most valuable for learning to translate
but imagine that pairs of sentences in
different languages are not as cheap and
easy to get as monolingual text where we
have sentences just in one language
researchers at google not me have
parallel data for 112 languages
consisting of 25 billion sentence pairs
to get to a thousand languages the
parallel data strategy cannot scale at
least not for now and machine
translation systems that train on any
available parallel data can also train
on additional monolingual data the crazy
part is that through back translation
and self-training they learn to
translate between languages for which
there is no parallel data but let's not
get ahead of us now our point here is
that to extend machine translation to a
thousand languages the best bet of the
authors is to collect monolingual data
of a thousand languages
then to train a model on the parallel
data they already have and also on all
monolingual sentences and bam they can
enable machine translation for a
thousand languages then great let's
gather some monolingual data for more
than a thousand languages it should be
easy right
right
no it's not kreutzer and collaborators
show that data gathering strategies that
work for high resource languages are
gathering way too much noise for low
resource languages and therefore cannot
be applied in the same way the problem
here is that to gather data for a
language one first needs to identify
whether text from the internet is
written in that language to do this at
internet level this language
identification should be fast so using a
transformer model is maybe not the best
idea
even worse after gathering the data
storing it before filtering can be
challenging and this is google speaking
with a lot of servers and data storage
okay so how did the authors proceed by
starting with the beginning i guess
which is determining the
1745 languages the authors would be
interested in scraping this number of
course is an upper bound of what will
come after data gathering and filtering
because it's a little bit too optimistic
to think that for all these languages
the crawl text would have high enough
quality
the list of
1745 languages is not containing 83
languages for which the authors already
have a lot of data
so they move on by training a simple and
lightweight language identification
model it is important for this one to be
fast because it will look at enormous
amounts of text at virtually the whole
internet
this model is a cld 3 model which is a
feed forward neural network working on
text represented as a bag of characters
basically counting how many times
certain character engrams so groups of
characters occur in the text
maybe you wonder why not bag of words
but bag of characters
well the authors are working with
thousands of languages where for a lot
of them it is not straightforward how to
split text into words since not all
languages are as benevolent as english
where words are separated by spaces and
sentences are separated by clear
punctuation signs
with character n-grams the models can be
applied on languages which are harder to
tokenize
they train this model on withside an
aggregation of proprietary and publicly
available text corpora with an average
of 800 000 tokens per language
but surprise the authors did not use
this model to start crawling the data
set just yet but just to test on which
of the
1745 languages the model performs well
enough because on some languages the
language classification error of the
language identifier is just too high so
they drop these languages keeping
1629 of them on these 100 629 remaining
languages they train another cld3 model
why didn't they use the other cld3 model
did just trained on a 1745
languages
we do not know for sure as the paper is
visibly written by many authors and it
looks like each single one of them did a
part in this pipeline and when writing
it up they sometimes fail to connect the
dots between the different paper
sections to motivate some steps properly
we can only think of the obvious reason
for retraining another model on just 1
629 languages because a classification
model with less output possibilities has
a better chance to not confuse languages
okay great with this lightweight
language identification model the
authors finally crawled the internet to
find text in one of these
1629 languages
and do you think they are done
not so fast the problems are just
starting because there's a lot of
garbage in the script text like for
example random sentences of
non-linguistic content that is fooling
the language identification model into
thinking it's one of the languages of
interest so the authors discard
sentences whose language does not
correspond to the language of the whole
document and they remove the sentences
which do not contain enough words that
are most frequent for the predicted
language there is even more filtering
going on here with clustering of
languages which are varieties of the
same language or more filtering based on
token frequency but there is still some
more filtering to do now that the raw
corpus is already gathered and the data
amounts are bounded the authors use a
more sophisticated and slower language
identification model to make even better
predictions on what the language of each
sentence is
yes you guessed correctly this more
complex language identifier is
transformer based
after even more filtering with this
identifier and sentence deduplication
some languages still needed more
filtering with language specific fixes
for example there were funny occurrences
where in scottish gaelic 570 million
sentences contain a token which means
download or cree that had almost only
lorem ipsum sentences
and this was it it was simple enough to
gather the data right
no it wasn't at all and the authors led
volunteers which are native speakers but
also non-speakers doing detective work
ordered 72 languages to estimate how
much usable data the authors ended up
with the median score is 80
which speaks a bit for the difficulty of
the problem of scraping the right data
and applying all the right filters for
such a large and diverse set of
languages okay so now that the data set
more or less stands the authors are
ready to train a machine translation
system on it not on all of it but on the
part of the languages that have enough
data which is 25 000 sentences before
the deduplication step in filtering yes
you heard right before the deduplication
not after this is again an unmotivated
design choice that the paper does not
care to explain so the authors choose
1057 languages which have 25 000
sentences before the duplication adds
the 83 high resource languages they
already had data for to set up an
impressive set of monolingual data but
wait there is more namely the 25 billion
sentence pairs of parallel data of
translation to and from english for 112
languages so it's just now that the
machine translation systems are ready to
train
for the modeling part there is not
really novelty from this paper which is
nothing bad since the main contribution
is the data set and the engineering work
to get models to train on it
so their modeling choices are pretty
standard the model learns to translate
the 112 languages with the help of the
parallel data that is available but as a
second objective it is simultaneously
trained on the monolingual data so on
the 1057 plus 83 languages with the mass
training objective which basically means
that random spans of text are masked out
and the model needs to predict the
masked tokens
it's like birth but instead of masking
individual tokens here we mask entire
groups of words the idea of the
simultaneous training on parallel and
monolingual data is that the parallel
data teaches the model to translate
between around 100 languages the masked
language modeling on monolingual data
teaches the model something useful about
language in general so that at the end
of training the model is able to not
only translate between 100 languages
with parallel data but also the rough
translations between english and the
rest of the languages
which comes in handy because now the
authors use another established
technique in machine translation called
self training meaning that the model can
continue training in a second stage by
using the two objectives we know so far
translation and mass language modeling
at span level but also trained to
translate on sentence translation pairs
that previous checkpoints of the model
have generated
so here we are with trained models on
more than a thousand languages there are
quite a number of ablations the authors
do but we will focus on two kinds of
experiments the first experiment is
comparing a 1.5 billion and the six
billion parameter model trained on a
combination of 112 languages with
parallel data and 206 languages with
monolingual data so we're not yet at a
thousand languages here unsurprisingly
the more parameters models have the
better they memorize
we mean capture the diversity of all
these languages at least when it comes
to translating into english
but the most interesting part was when
the authors compared the model trained
on 200 languages with one trained on a
thousand languages what would we expect
here
well of course the model trained with a
thousand languages can translate between
more languages duh
but the surprising part is that adding
so many as a thousand languages from
which most are low resource and noisier
in quality does not interfere with the
translation performance of most high
resource languages this is a bit
unexpected because previous work by
zothan and collaborators made us think
that adding many low resource languages
in the data set of monolingual sentences
can hurt model performance the
explanation of the authors is not
necessarily proven or exact but they
hypothesized that after a certain number
of languages the probability for each
added language to be similar to an
already existing one increases
in other words it might seem complex to
translate between a thousand languages
if they don't have any similarities but
they do which explains the observed
effect
unfortunately this paper does not have a
full suit of experiments that gradually
increases the number of languages from
the hundreds to the thousands to see at
what language number this effect starts
to appear and whether the improvement is
continuous or makes a discontinuous jump
now thinking a bit further about this
what would be interesting to know in
this highly multilingual regime is
whether languages with a lot of
resources that were seen more often by
the model somehow affect or culturally
imprint the low resource languages more
concretely we are wondering whether a
multilingual model that has seen a lot
of english but not so much romanian
would think more in english than in
romanian introducing english
specificities in romanian translations
but now it's time to conclude this video
by noting that the contributions of this
paper are great the thing to be unhappy
about is that the release of this paper
does not come with a release of the data
or of the models
we guess that google has little
incentive to open source the research
they base their google translate product
on but speaking of open source look at
meta's response to this paper they train
a 200 language machine translation
system and open source it i guess google
wins at a number of languages but meta
ai wins at making its research more
accessible to a wider public so what are
your thoughts on this let us know in the
comments and we hope you learned
something today and hope to see you in
the next video
okay bye
[Music]
you